art is about how we function in the
world and science for me is how the
world functions around us there's always
a balance between making something look
just amazingly cool and awesome versus
representing very correctly the ideas
and process my job is to sort of oversee
all of the visual aspects of our science
communication for the public so if I had
to pick sort of my favorite piece it'd
have to be this one this is a
representation of what our Milky Way
galaxy might look like if we can look
down on it from above knowing of what
the Milky Way looks like is kind of 10th
mountain having someone like Draca down
in the middle of Times Square and say
okay map out all of Manhattan standing
at this spot but what was interesting
for me about this piece of art was there
are actually features that I put in here
for artistic and best-guess reasons that
have subsequently been discovered in
particular this this outer arm here it
looked terribly lopsided as a galaxy if
you cut off this arm here and you had
the other arm really nicely done here
and then the couple years later Hannes
Dane who studies hydrogen gas and Milky
Way found an arm that followed almost
exactly its location and length
sometimes a piece of art can be
considered a hypothesis but then people
can go and take further data when I
start into a project the goal is to
really come up with something that works
just purely at artistic level but if I
were to show this to the researchers I
want them to look at and go oh yeah
right that's what it looks like a good
piece of science visualization art is
kind of like a movie trailer
tells you just enough that you want to
go see it and you have an idea of what
you're gonna get when you go there but
it doesn't tell the whole story and you
need to go to the movie if you really
want to get the whole answer I just came
up with that on the spot
I am so using that from here on